our state has made some great progress
in the fight against kova 19 thanks to
our state's task force this according to
the governor
the nevada kova 19 response relief and
recovery task force was created in march
of 2020 by governor steve sisselak
they wanted to utilize both private and
public sources
to help with our state's response 12
million dollars was used to purchase ppe
and connect students with internet
access and laptops among other things
the governor says the year-long effort
has been a long journey
but an inspiration about how quickly our
state can come together
at the beginning with the testing and
they're really under it
playing understating what they did we
didn't have test tubes
we didn't have swaps we didn't have the
transfer
agent that that swab had to go into we
didn't have any of that
they had to go find all of this for us
and then we had to assemble it in order
to do tests
i mean so much has happened sisalak also
credited the task force for helping umc
with its covid testing
they were able to secure equipment and
supplies to develop local testing as
early as april
we'll break down the report as well as
the task force next step coming up
tonight at 6.